as the final season of Breaking Bad was  in post Vince and I used to take these  long walks down the the back out at  lunchtime the back alleys of Burbank you  know some of the uglier streets in Los  Angeles but somehow very conducive to  conversation and we would just talk  about what the show would be and we got  more more excited oh I have to say  probably 85% of the things that we  talked about didn't happen but there is  a core there's a core of things that we  talked about that did happen and one of  the ones that excited me the most right  at the beginning was the idea of doing a  sort of a midnight run episode with with  Jimmy and Mike and it took us it took us  48 episodes to get there was until  season 5 that we got there but but we  did get there and happiness happy to say